I turned on the TV last night to watch
the Golden Globe Awards a little bit I
think Joe Koy got the gig 10 days before
the Golden Globes because I read that he
said that and I was like well that's
weird to be 10 days out and still not
have a host nobody wanted to host this
thing bunch of high-profile comedians
reportedly turned down the gig including
Chris Rock finally everyone's getting
smart those shows are [__] difficult
to do you know apparently found out yeah
they they're they're they're panning him
but I didn't even understand someone
said that he was mean about uh Taylor
Swift the big difference between the
Golden Globes and the NFL on the Golden
Globes we have fewer camera shots of
Taylor Swift I swear there just where to
go to here sorry about that about that
they cut to Taylor Swift and she gave
like this mean look stern look at him
and I thought she was joking around but
you see various media reports I think
page six even put out a report saying if
looks could kill like the Taylor swi was
actually mad at Joe Koy which was
ridiculous guy should have come out and
and talked about the fact that they
chose him 10 days ago because no one
else in Hollywood wanted the [__] gig
and then work from there that's the
premise I would have gone with and said
no wonder no one wants this gig can't
make fun of anybody any anymore I felt
bad for the dude because 10 days because
I've talked to Jimmy about this and he
does such a great job with the uh jimble
Kimble with the Academy Awards he
prepares for like six months I mean he's
got he's got a whole and and and Molly
is the executive producer I mean they
work their asses off on that thing 10
days yeah you're you're doomed not
nearly enough time yeah standing up
there and telling those jokes to a bunch
of people who don't want to be laughed
at is the biggest bummer in the world
that's why I always praise Jimmy and the
job he does with it because Hollywood
has no sense of humor about
itself and those people in that audience
do not want to be made fun of they're
very concerned about their image and
they're publicist I mean if you're
shelling out 25 30% of your income on
publicists and agents and managers you
don't want to be goofed on on television
you want to be treated like the serious
actor like you're doing the most
important [__] on the planet so to go up
there and and be the host of the Golden
Globes it's a ridiculous gig you got to
sit there and goof on people but goof on
them in such a pleasant way that they're
like smiling afterwards oh that was nice
like I was watching this guy do his
thing last night and he was talking
about Robert dairo and Robert dairo was
laughing hysterically like he was in the
movie Cape Fear and you're like dairo
could have been just you know Stone
like nasty during it but he seemed to
like it but you never know I mean who
wants to play Russian Roulette on live
television with your career I mean what
the hell it's as stupid as [__] gig I
mean comedians are supposed to be funny
and the only way to be funny is to be
cynical so why would you go to an event
where they don't let you be cynical
because they'll boo
you and